The Joe Rogan Experience well look even
like with this this Trump thing man it's
like
it's like I was saying how so many
people still believe the Russia
collusion story which was all made up
man and you can go like you can go
follow this whole thing it was all made
up and they knew it they knew what they
were doing there's that clip by the way
before any of this stuff is before
Donald Trump ever took office do you
ever see uh the Chuck Schumer six ways
to Sunday
you were telling me about it last night
you were saying we should watch it we
should we should play this because and
let me just let me just preface it
briefly to kind of set up what's so
amazing about it there are these
occasional moments where even like I
said the thing with Chris Murphy just
happens to blur it out like oh yeah we
our policy is overthrew yeah right like
there are these moments where kind of
like these rare moments of honesty from
the kind of leaders of the regime yeah
and the this one comes because Rachel
Maddow asks him like in impromptu thing
and she says that she leads that so but
this is just and just so you know this
is Donald Trump has been elected but he
hasn't uh he hasn't been um he's a
president-elect here so it's after the
election but he's not president yet so
this was about him tweeting uh something
here but he's he's taking these
shot this antagonism is taunting to the
intelligence Community you take on the
intelligence Community they have six
ways from Sunday at getting back at you
so even for a practical supposedly
hard-nosed businessman he's being really
dumb to do this what do you think the
intelligence Community would do if they
were I don't know but I from what I am
told they are very upset with how he has
treated them and talked about them
so and what happened right before that
is that Rachel Maddow goes um she goes
all right I'm sorry to put you on the
spot here but Donald Trump just tweeted
this thing about the intelligence
Community any thoughts on that so it's
not like he was prepared for this right
his the most powerful senator in America
his initial gut reaction was like well
dude you're taking on the intelligent I
mean you want to go up against the CIA
you think you're going to win that fight
yeah like they're going to get you and
this was already after they had already
been uh they were spying on his campaign
they had already kind of begun framing
him for this whole this whole Russia
thing which was always nonsense and it
started with um uh you know the Steele
dossier and all that stuff and then they
were spying on Carter page who was like
a pretty low level advisor in Donald
Trump's campaign and the allegation was
that the Russians had offered him a huge
stake in like one of their biggest
energy companies if he could uh get
Donald Trump to remove all of this
sanctions that we had at the time on
Russia which on on the face of it made
no sense because he's like a low-level
advisor on the campaign now he's not
even in the administration was this
based on intercepted emails no this was
based off the Steele dossier which was
uh opposition research that Hillary
Clinton had funded uh where she hired
this British spy to go like dig up dirt
on Donald Trump and they put together
this whole dossier alleging that he was
um you know he had been in bed with
Russia for years he was compromised it
was the that the prostitutes were peeing
on him and all this like crazy and
they all knew it was unverified they all
knew it was like the and all of it
almost all of it was ended up being
disproven uh but so when they went to
Carter pit but just to understand like
the idea of trying to bribe a low-level
advisor on a campaign to then somehow
take over the administration once he got
it's it'd be like on the level of if
someone was like um we are going to
bribe the door guy at the mothership to
make sure that the Joe Rogan Experience
only talks about these subjects and
you're like I mean even though there's a
loose connection between you and the guy
who works at the mothers the idea that
he would ever then be able to come in
and take over the show and control it
just made no sense but we now know
that the CIA
told the FBI that Carter page was a good
guy that he was a he was a CIA um
informant uh then they they so they told
the FBI they're like no no he's not a
spy he's one of ours so just lay up and
then the FBI uh lied about that on the
fisa application this was the only guy
who went down for the frame job was this
one FBI uh lawyer for
misrepresenting the what the CIA said
but basically he
the C they said that he was um
approached by Russians and uh that he
was approached by a group of Russians to
see if he would turn and work for them
and the CIA uh were like yes he was
and he came right back to us and told us
about it
and then when they were putting in the
application for the fisa warrant the FBI
said he was approached by these Russians
and the CIA confirmed it
so they they said that the CIA confirmed
that he was approached by these guys but
they left out the part that the CIA said
and he came right back to us and told us
about it so that one guy was the only
guy who got charged did he get because
it was so no jail time but he did get
charged card to page no no the FBI agent
who uh FBI lawyer who lied on the
application oh Carter page they had
three fisa court warrants on them they
spied on them all up and down never been
charged with anything because he wasn't
a spy right and there's look that Donald
Trump even now with all these charges
right he's never been charged with
um treason he's never been charged with
inciting uh an Insurrection because they
know they can't get him on those charges
so what they're getting them on is all
these like novel legal theories well
it's not very clear that he violated the
statute but if we interpret it this way
we could make the argument for the first
time ever that this was actually a
violation of law it's all like they're
grasping at straws and it's very clearly
like they've weaponized is the legal
system against this guy it's not a
coincidence that all of these
indictments are coming down right now
like why why was the January 6th thing
why would any of this be coming down
right now right all those other people
in January 6 they got charged and
arrested immediately it was determined
by the powers that be you know with the
corporate media the Deep State all of
the establishment that he was
unacceptable and that's not new to
Donald Trump there were a lot of
candidates who have been determined to
be unacceptable Ron Paul was was
unacceptable Bernie Sanders was
unacceptable Tulsi gabbard was
unacceptable and you saw like the
machine be weaponized against all of
them to keep them out but Trump beat the
machine the difference is Trump won I
mean there's other differences but but
the guy who they determined was not
acceptable ended up winning and part of
what was so powerful about that
is that it kind of destroyed the
um the illusion of inevitability that I
think progressives rely on that you know
like progressives will very confidently
tell you that you're on the wrong side
of History
you know which is like a really
interesting thing to say if you think
about it like you're on the wrong side
of History meaning like it's a guarantee
that history is moving in my direction
and I'm telling you how you will be
judged in the future based off how you
feel right now and they kind of have
good reason to feel that way because
they have been kind of moving in the
direction that they want to move in but
it was just like
we just had the first black president
and now we will have the first female
president and of course uh you know uh
this throwback bigot uh male chauvinist
Donald Trump could never possibly win
like this is what's going to happen in
history now is Hillary Clinton is the
next president how is it not happening
how are they going to stop him from
winning again
I uh they're trying oh yeah that's what
all these uh indictments are right now
the problem is it has the opposite
effect on his base
it doesn't make people reluctant it
makes people more convinced that there's
a conspiracy against him it makes people
more convinced that there's corruption
that's fighting against him I I think
personally that Trump was at his most
vulnerable within the Republican primary
at the very beginning I thought he for
the first time to me he seemed like he
was very out of step with his own base
he's sitting there still bragging about
operation warp speed and how he saved
hundreds of millions of lives by
developing the vaccine he was getting
booed a few times at his own speeches
um he just seemed kind of out of touch
and it seemed like you know it seemed
like the energy of his campaign wasn't
2016 which was make America great again
this was like my Vengeance tour they
screwed me I lost but I really won we're
gonna I'm gonna come back and win again
and it seemed to me like that wasn't
really connecting and then you know this
before DeSantis got in the race but it
was heavily speculated that he would be
getting in the race and you know he was
like this guy who has a very good record
on kovit at least compared to all the
other Governors just about all the other
Governors
um and there there just seemed to me
like there was an open thing there was
like a vulnerability and then they
raided his house in Mar-A-Lago
and I felt like that that guaranteed
Trump front run like that that
guaranteed it form because as soon as
they did that it was like oh now it's
like it's it's shifted right back to
this like look what they're doing to
your guy they want to not give you the
chance to vote for this guy they're
going to weaponize the justice system
against this guy because you like him
they're not and they're doing it to him
because they want to do it to you it
kind of gave him like all this energy
back and so there's a real Dynamic to
that where his numbers go up every time
a new indictment comes out yeah people
aren't buying into it because it's not
like
you know look it's just so obvious that
it's politicized you know the
interesting thing there's an interesting
thing about the law like people have
this conception of what the law is and
then there's the reality of it like
people have this conception of like
there's a rule written written down on a
piece of paper and that's the rule and
if you break that rule you broke the law
if you don't break that rule you didn't
break the law but that's not really how
it works it's like in the same way like
down to the lowest level if you get
pulled over by a cop you know there's
times where he could give you a ticket
or he could let you off with a warning
you know and like sometimes it's just
how that guy feels right maybe he knew
you right maybe stuff she goes oh
Joe Rogan Alex off of the warning you
know what I mean like there could be so
many different factors well like just
just for example okay so um uh James
Clapper you know he was the uh the
Director of National Intelligence as
basically the head of the Shadow
government that's the highest position
in the Deep State you're that the CIA
answers to you you know you oversee the
CIA in the NSA and FBI and all this
stuff and he lied to Congress very
blatantly like no question about it he
was asked point blank is the NSA
involved in any bulk data collection on
American citizens said no we're not
doing that then Ed Snowden came out and
exposed that he clearly was he was the
the dni like he knew this okay he lied
to Congress
why is he arrested for it it's like
because there's no political will to
arrest that guy he is of the deep State
he's one of the top guys that he's not
getting arrested now Michael Cohen lied
to Congress he got a month wrong when he
was talking about uh a deal that that he
was working on for Trump he said it
happened in you know June but it was
really in January or something like that
he got charged with that and because
they wanted to put pressure on him to
get him to flip on Donald Trump which he
did
um so that's it's not like there are
crimes that are committed all the time
there's just no political will there's
no desire to arrest that person and I
think the thing that's wild about this
with Trump is that if you think of all
the crimes that presidents have
committed
the idea that this is what one of them
is actually going to go down for is
insane like Bush instituted torture
you know what I mean Obama murdered
American citizens without charges
these guys lied us into Wars by the way
every war is illegal you know the the
supreme law of the land is the
Constitution and it says only Congress
can declare war the last declared war
was World War II
every war since then has been an illegal
War anyone could be arrested for this at
any time so it's it's the the legal
defense is that they're military actions
not Wars do you know that thing in
Vietnam it probably smelled like a war
to you but not not a war Korea wasn't a
war Iraq wasn't a war Afghanistan Libya
Syria Somalia Yemen none of those
rewards you know it's anyone if there
was any political will any one of these
presidents could be arrested for for any
number of crimes and yet they're not but
yet Trump
didn't give back the classified
information quickly enough even after
they asked him up he's got a he's got to
be indicted for that even though other
presidents have done pretty much the
same thing no he's got to be indicted
for that what is the the Georgia thing
is interesting because he was going to
have a press conference where he was
going to reveal all of the information
that proves that he was telling the
truth about the Georgia election being
rigged yeah he didn't have the press
conference yes well this is a thing that
I gotta say is a kind of knock on Trump
here that you know this is a thing his
lawyers uh Sydney Powell and Rudy
Giuliani who just turned himself in uh
uh into custody today
um but they they would always say this
after 2020. we have proof that millions
of votes were stolen from Donald Trump
and will be releasing this soon and then
it just never kind of comes so I don't
know what he thinks he's going to tell
us about that the issue with the thing
in Georgia where I I will grant there's
like a little bit of a gray area there
um and I think that look it's there
there is a gray area there it's kind of
like when they impeach Trump over
Ukraine there was like a little bit of a
gray area of like what exactly he did
it's just that when you look at things
of all the crimes that presidents
commits the idea that you go after a
present for this it's so petty compared
to these greater crimes but like
he kind of he called the Secretary of
State in Georgia and was kind of like I
need you to find me these votes but he
was saying he was like look there's been
fraud I know there's been fraud you got
to go look for it and the guy's like I
don't see any evidence that there's
fraud here and he's like find it I know
there's fro you know
he was putting pressure on the guy to go
look but it's not as if he was telling
the guy I need you to commit fraud right
he wasn't telling him I want you to flip
votes or I want you to manipulate
something he's like I want you to go
find where the fraud is right because I
so you'd almost have to prove that he
didn't really believe that right in
order to prove you know you know because
if there was really fraud he has every
right to tell the guy to go find it
right so now so now they're arguing that
he didn't and in the indictment they
argued that he knew it
and he was uh like he knew that there
was no fraud but was still trying to get
the guy to go find it
and the case that they're using to argue
that is that he had advisors around him
who told him that the election was legit
the problem with that is that that
doesn't prove at all that Trump believed
those guys just because they told him
that right if there's one thing I'm
fairly confident in I believe Donald
Trump believes he won the election in
2020.